Ladies and gentlemen, in my short stay,
Chicago has been very nice to me.
And of course Chicago's a drinking town,
and earlier this week,
(audience cheering)
earlier this week the Goose Island Brewery
announced they were creating
(audience cheering)
a special ale in my honor.
I decided to pay them a visit
and learn how you make
a Conan O'Brien brew.
(audience cheering and applauding)
♪ Beer, we like to drink beer ♪
♪ Beer, we like to drink our beer ♪
This is Greg Hall.
Right.
You are the brewmaster
here at Goose Island.
True.
Is brewmaster an official title?
Do you need a certificate?
Actually it's master brewer
is kind of the official one.
What do you prefer, master
brewer or brewmaster?
I think the brewmaster sounds--
You gotta admit, it just sounds great.
Yeah.
Behold, brewmaster.
Yes.
(audience laughing)
♪ Beer ♪
Come with me.
♪ Beer, oh, beer ♪
Whoa! (screams)
We got Will, Will is the
head brewer of our brewpub.
Hey, Will.
Hello.
We have Ryan, his able-bodied assistant.
The term is called Brewpies.
Brewpies.
The women that stand up in
the window and watch us brew.
Right.
They're Brewpies.
Brewpies.
They try to get with the brewers.
(audience laughing)
♪ Oh yeah, drink my beer ♪
(audience cheering)
Oh!
♪ Open beer ♪
(audience laughing)
(grunting) Son of a bitch!
Laughed at me, laughed at my naked body!
Do you also wear protective
glasses, why is that?
Hey look, I got my beer
goggles on. (laughs)
Did you hear what I said?
Beer goggles.
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
What we thought was we would
make a kind of a red ale.
Conan Red, tell me about the
ingredients of Conan's beer.
Well, we're gonna use some...
And refer to it as Conan's
beer in the third person.
When we're making Conan's beer--
Mm-hmm, is that Conan
O'Brien the talk show host?
Yeah.
That guy's funny.
Funny guy.
If it's a Conan beer it
should have a big head on it,
you know what I'm saying?
It should have a big head.
We can do that.
Is that a funny--
We can manage that.
I have high, sharp cheekbones.
What could capture that in a beer?
Could be the glass we serve it in.
Very nice.
I have a very thin,
almost nonexistent ass.
(audience laughing)
What would you do?
Stemware.
Stemware, nice, I like it.
Here's my pitch, all the world
knows that I'm very pale.
This is a shirtless photo of me
taken after a week in the sun.
A week.
Conan's pale, that's why
I pitch to you right now,
Conan O'Brien Pale Ale.
(audience laughs and cheers)
And we'd offer, for people who want it,
a Conan O'Brien Pale, Pale Ale.
(audience laughing)
Is that a good plan?
[Greg] I think it's a good idea.
♪ Beer, beer, we like to drink our beer ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
♪ Beer beer, we like to drink our beer ♪
♪ Beer, beer, drink our beer ♪
Well, I think we...
(audience cheers and claps)
I think we should have an expert
test the Conan O'Brien Ale
so here to do that, once
again, George Wendt.
Let's get him out here.
(crowd applauds and cheers)
Thank you, Conan.
Yeah, there you go.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
[Crowd] Chug, chug, chug,
chug, chug, chug, chug, chug!
(Chewbacca roars)
(crowd cheering)
I guess that means it's good.
We'll be right back.
Wilco will be here!